[Aplausos]
e se a natureza fosse regra na educação
em vez da sessão do trio convida os a
teletransportar em si não precisa de se
levantar
usei a vossa máquina é transporte
lanches vossos olhos e sintam que cheira
a vossa criança entre o apresentar a
vocês nesta experiência e peçam que nos
recordam o meio lixo e positivo da voz
ênfase está convosco por que não ouvir o
que estão a fazer
[Música]
convites agora que está em sala podem
abrir passagem
matar não é que senta aí quem é que se
lembrou dos momentos passados ao ar
livre
quem aqui não tenho a criança sentada no
vosso colo boa
deixem no ficar exatamente 3 no ser
humano que vai falar aqui hoje uma das
imagens que vai a minha memória está
insensível tem a ver com corridas é casa
de meus pais fica numa zona criada de
pinhais junto a um dos afluentes
arrecadava e o fundo da ria é é
pantanoso cheira muito mal mas eu
habitar um luxo para cargas que meu
irmão tenha sempre da higiene e guardava
religiosamente as bordas das bravatas do
bacalhau que a mãe usava prova os
meninos de 2 bots duas canas é sigilo do
ovo de pesca a isaaa pescando
caranguejos
queremos lá saber quando os caranguejos
e tínhamos apanhar fugir era quando
voltavam cheios e junto da água e só
vamos manter o pé no chão ao som do trio
virou vamos querer dizer viu correr em
direção à água bayeux em o melhor
chocolate sempre porque contava mesmo
era o irmão com os riscos que além das
funções mais los efetivamente quando nos
pedem para recordar momentos de crianças
felizes empresa tive pensarem bem quase
sempre são crianças a correr ea gritar
é rir esconder as brincarem ensina
natureza é de 13 elementos naturais
estão sempre presentes em publicidades o
anúncio mesmo alguns livros para
crianças sempre acontecerá na natureza
efetivamente é essência do ser humano
as crianças precisam brincar precisam
estar na natureza e sua seu gato falava
em e correrem e em conhecer o mundo
então é questiona por que ineficaz am
hoje em dia existem tão poucos momentos
na natureza na jornada das nossas
crianças
esta é uma mensagem e essa é uma
pergunta que tem sido feita à volta do
mundo e muitos têm sido os estúdios e é
comprovar exatamente os benefícios que
uma inspeção na natureza pode ter para
as crianças
existe mesmo alguns autores que por
exemplo fechar logo descobriu exatamente
que a uma perturbação desenvolvida com a
falta de contato e exposição à natureza
chama-o e perturbação défice natureza o
qual poderia estar relacionado com o
desenvolvimento do estado de saúde
mental como por exemplo a opçã e isso
fez-me pensar em outras situações e em
outros estados podem ser identificados
hoje em dia nas nossas crianças como a
perturbação défice de atenção e
hiperatividade será dos pais é culpa
será uma incapacidade temporária das
crianças da escola será no ar do que
elas comem eu acredite que grande parte
dos casos identificados hoje em dia com
estas perturbações terão assinado
exatamente com uma falta de contato com
a natureza uma falta do livro usado das
próprias crianças
essa criança não seja livre natureza
precisa explorar precisa de ir pro mundo
sem regras nós continuamos
constantemente a colocá los dentro das
salas de aula horários muito estipulados
são regras muito muito vincadas nós
teremos nós próprios em closer orc
espírito livre enquanto as carteirinhas
e obtém em portugal não só no mundo têm
vindo a alguns autores a falar sobre
estima e alertar seu nome como e duarte
sa carlos neto josé pacheco
devolver a criança à natureza a sua a
sua origem e devolver a ela a gestão do
seu próprio tem a sua biologia e é com
este intuito que eu tô aqui os para
amplificar as vozes dessas pessoas eu
pudesse chegar à decisão os locais
precisos nas finais liga todos vós que
façamos a algum barulho e então abrir a
este leque e estas possibilidades para
preciso então tem ferramentas para estes
grupos que já estão em movimento passará
mesmo hassan e apresente alguma
um rapaz de talvez conseguem estão a
exportar agora para que o que sentem ao
ver esta imagem
o que é que acham que estas crianças
estão a sentir neste vai e eu estava lá
vai ser mais fácil foi uma tarde super
super divertida
mesmo as crianças estavam eufóricas nós
tínhamos prometido
queremos construir 12 no jardim da da
cozinha e todos queriam participar entre
nós desejamos esta corda gigante lá numa
loja e tudo estavam envolvidos como
vocês vêem todos esses grana corda
essência céu esta imagem todos chrome a
corda todos felizes transportam para
outra dimensão eo pis
é uma equipa e estou contente por fazer
parte de uma brincadeira lente ocular
não está preocupado eu confio não vai
ter já viram os filhos deu não dá
vontade de rekkam eu fazia um sorriso
mais dias da vida viu aí onde todas as
crianças vê crianças a brincar na
natureza inspira no exterior o chefe do
grupo a lavar o pneu de um caminhão que
nós encontramos que é servida sempre por
valores ou este grupo num bairro social
indica vi nós prometemos fazer vulcões
que entrarem explosão e os foram ao
bairro está com as próprias mãos esta
lama constrói vulcões ou este grupo
etário em uma quinta biológica fazer 11
a atividade de orientação são imagens
que fazem acreditar acredita neste meu
sonho é que as crianças precisam voltar
à natureza precisam estar em constante
estímulo todos os dias
então se houvesse um museu para explorar
o jardim de infância que permite às
crianças passaram o dia todo no meio da
natureza atrás opus a colecionar
figurinhas andar atrás dos riachos
ativadas o que elas quisessem
esse modelo pudesse ter um impacto na
percepção que os portugueses estão a
identificação precoce de alguns países
na europa já chegaram algumas soluções
já encontraram algumas respostas press
são países como a dinamarca a holanda a
mesma suíça suécia a frança e inglaterra
e o que eu se encontraram foi um deu
tempo das crianças tarde de segunda a
sexta no meio da natureza em que o
adulto é um mero guia e acompanhado das
suas aprendizagens chamadas escolas de
floresta foi school dos vários termos
usados estão mais comum e voz é
exatamente esta
as crianças estão em contacto com a
natureza e aqui vocês podem pensar
estava em uma sessão outras culturas e
dizer atuar à frente à holanda na
alemanha é impossível que isso não vai
acontecer
esqueça vai dispensar um sempre assim
vamos tentar achar uma porta pra sempre
as nossas crianças e as suas infâncias
existem bastante difícil também
associados é isto como o espírito equipa
como vimos a público é própria
autoperceção das crianças é própria' a
autoconsciência de cinco das suas
capacidades
também a nível da autoestima a danos
imensos para as crianças que estão neste
projeto
então os próprios dizem isso a nível de
saúde física por curiosidade
existem estudos que revelam um
melhoramento em nível de estado de asma
das crianças e você se pergunta já não
existem os escritórios e aquelas
atividades de arvorismo que às vezes as
pessoas levam os alunos
isso não chega nessa não chega ele fez
impacto em nível desenvolvimento
cognitivo das crianças um dia por semana
com cinco dias por semana
não tem comparação o impacto é tão maior
que as crianças conseguem ter com base
para a sua estrutura desenvolvimento
como o do futuro da natureza e todos
estes edifícios que ouvi falar e
portanto a nível de resolução de
conflitos e outros
isso vai beneficiar imenso eu vejo esse
tipo de deus a não só o investimento a
nível das infâncias e na educação das
crianças mas sobretudo o investimento na
prevenção e na promoção de duch mais
conscientes do nosso planeta mais
ligados com a nossa natureza e
principalmente cuidadores são adultos no
futuro próximas gerações que vão estar
em muito mais conexã e vão ajudar a
pedir o nosso habitar em 2015
vivi sete meses paulo
também tive no ano 2000 e 72 um ano
depois do andré e crianças e jovens numa
vila essencialmente rural com
agricultores e as imagens também
transita que agora são exatamente muitas
delas acontecidas aqui e é uma
experiência que o partido sempre por ter
um impacto em mim e eu acho que pode
acabar por ter um impacto em todas as
pessoas
as crianças não faltam com esta conexão
da natureza muito acentuada
é natural que são crianças com uma
grande consciência das suas coisas têm
um cuidado enorme com as suas coisas
lavam suas roupas ajuda nas tarefas de
casa aqui estão com sorte enorme
e é bem visto na mão daquela unidade que
ajudam nas tarefas da alimentação
preparam os seus aliados suas refeições
almoço sempre em conjunto está muito bom
a moção sempre em conjunto e se as
crianças têm mesas têm bancos na cozinha
não é por causa disso pessoas preferem
mesmo etária ali sentados no jardim mas
não sem antes lavar em todos os seus
próprios efetivamente mas vão à escola
como é óbvio
toda a gente tem que ir à escola parte
da educação formal é muito importante
mas é esta experiência mostrou misto e o
quer defender isto eu sou suspeita para
falar se calar sobre o contato com a
natureza tive o privilégio de nascer em
uma família de agricultores de
mecanismos dos hits rodeada de natureza
mas eu sei que se transformou em uma
pessoa muito mais com shane do nosso
mundo e muito mais atento aos ajustes e
ali e principalmente com chita mãe do
outro e nem própria e eu acredito que é
seu a forma ideal de poder educar os
meus filhos porque são os meus filhos
porque não os vossos filhos
os vossos nets os vossos sobrinhos as
crianças que estão na vossa vida
poderiam ensurdecer educadas neste tipo
de premissas as crianças precisam
brincar mais do que está escrito na
carta dos seus direitos
elas têm necessidade de explorar o mundo
cheirá-lo sentiu sem enrolar neu e
precisam de fazer não sozinhos não
apenas com outras crianças mas
essencialmente com os seus pais
estes devem ser os principais
impulsionadores e produtores da
brincadeira do jogo nas crianças
acompanhando o dia a dia nas suas
aprendizagens e mostrando de gestão de
mão dada neste caminho
e o mesmo acontece com os agentes de
educação
cada criança precisa de medidas iguais
de jogo e regras é brincadeira
aprendem competências que nos vão servir
a vida toda
a nível da resolução de conflitos a
nível de frustrações internas e nível de
comunicação com o outro
esse esforço foi natureza vai ter um
impacto enorme tamanho do nosso planeta
e portanto eu defendo é hoje do mar a
ligação das crianças com a natureza é
hoje preocupar-nos nos produtos que
vamos ter amanhã as próximas gerações
que vão controlar o nosso mundo eo nosso
planeta
as crianças saiam por ser crianças
minhas disse que não tem mal nenhum e
ninguém diz que só por não estarem a dar
esse acesso elas têm mais do direito
fazer greve ou feijão e o grão durante
uma semana eu vou dizer não se preocupe
obrigada
[Aplausos]